you guys invited the um Vice fell I
can't remember his name um to one of
your Retreats where you had the uh the
fight session you know with the mmm with
the MMA guys you offered an opportunity
to war remembers to get into the octagon
and test themselves
um what was that guy's name again
uh Matt Matt okay so yeah like what was
the story behind the story without it I
know you've probably talked about it
before but I haven't heard it but you
know you invited him in you know with
Goodwill to say you know come on in take
a look at how things are meet some of
the members watch what we do and then
the final produced piece when I saw it
was really about
um a couple stories behind some girls
who felt whatever they felt at that time
um and wanted to talk to Vice about it
to make the Tates look bad what really
happened when that guy Matt was behind
the scenes with you okay so first of all
he said he wanted to do a documentary on
the war when it turns out it was just a
hit based on type now Tristan and I
rightly called that it was a hit piece
uh Andrew's project was they gonna do it
anyway let's at least let them see the
reality Now Matt came in speaking about
journalistic integrity about the fact
that he put forward an objective did you
guys use videographers to film from your
angle as well too while he was there
with his guys
um to a certain extent but not for the
final interview which is a okay because
that final interview my goodness take
absolutely destroyed him to the point
where from the three-hour interview they
advice could only use you know the last
minute which was me you know getting
upset and walking out right that was
when the true agenda came out so Matt's
exactly where I'll be objective I'll
show both sides of the story that event
was incredibly positively
transformational for everyone who went
through guys who fought and the guys who
didn't fight there was a real Buzz you
know you bring high quality men together
everyone examines their weaknesses where
they can improve in life does something
challenging is what men have done all
throughout history that write a passage
we were talking about that before we
launched you have to test yourself if
you're going to learn combat skills you
must test yourself get in the ring get
punched in the face see what happens
yeah that's what it was all about in a
very risk managed way very responsible
incredible event absolutely incredible
super positive they didn't show any of
the positivity even Matt himself was
enjoying it the other guy Jamie said to
me uh yeah you know this is this is he
likes his boxing as well he said I see
them good with what you're doing here
there was a lot of positivity and there
was a bunch of shots that they seen they
a bunch of scenes that they shot were
really positive men supporting each
other after Matt spawned with Tate I
went over and gave him some water and
gave him a bit of a pep talk that but
all of that was cut out so that I could
push this negative agenda so
I think the reason there's been such a
backlash against voice and it has been
pretty intense and against you know that
the people involved they came in saying
they'd do something objective and of
course they're going to push a narrative
I get that but they completely cut out
all the positive elements and tried to
skew things they they falsely edited
some of takes reactions you know trying
to show that he was reacting to one of
Matt's questions when he wasn't there
was a lot of very shady very unethical
practices put forward both in the
filming and the you know the final edit
of that and so to me it just goes to
show that yes Vice is trash yes a lot of
you know modern day journalism is is
just propaganda and certain types of
people on the political Spectrum pushing
a certain agenda uh so the whole thing
was quite laughable to be honest the
warring remains an extremely positive
group that event was extremely positive
and everyone on the vice team knows it
and they saw it even though their
corporate Masters made sure they put out
just a blatant one-sided hit piece in
the final documentary yeah you do have
to be very careful with the mainstream
media I learned that lesson in two
thousand 10 and 11 when they started
asking for commentary on this bill that
was passing legislation here that I was
the lead Lobby I was I was working with
the lead lobbyist on and um they brought
in major TV shows in my office we had to
move all the furniture around they do
lighting the makeup all that kind of
stuff and they completely Twisted the
um end product around
um it's you know it's a bit of a shame
because growing up you know you look at
the media and you respect it because
there's an authority there that a camera
is on with lighting and they're properly
dressed and they look like they're
righteous and all that but they really
aren't uh if you invite the media into
your life my recommendation is do it
knowing that they're probably going to
modify the story to whatever narrative
they want to push so record it on your
end have a professional videographer
even if it's just cell phones even if
you have some sort of recording from a
different angle from your perspective in
real life as they're doing it from the
different angle then you've at least got
something to lean on because you because
you simply can't trust them and that's
just the reality of the world today
that's that's what the media has become
we saw what happened with um Elon Musk
the other day with that BBC
it's been amazing I mean I always knew
the media were biased I've been media
trained you know when I was working um
in Australia in various capacities and
in various corporate roles and so my
policy has always been just don't touch
and don't have anything to do with it
but again to speak out to the tanks have
gone public that meant seeing firsthand
what happens you know with the
journalists and with the media types in
real life and then seeing the final
product that they push out my goodness
these people are Shameless there's no
such thing as journalistic Integrity
anymore there's no such thing as
professionalism in journalism these guys
are here to push a certain agenda and
they truly don't care about truth it's
it's wild to see it's been a really
eye-opening even for me as a guy who's
you know seen a bit of the world and I
Am Naturally pretty skeptical about
people or journalists and like even I
was shocked at how low down unethical
scumbagging their behavior has been
around this whole tape situation
yeah and the amount of influence that
they stole wield is uh shocking you know
to say the least I have to believe it's
dying I mean you have to be pretty high
level program sheep to actually think
that the media is anything other than a
propaganda machine driven to make you a
certain type of you know easily
malleable human yeah well when they
de-platform you that you know that was
the first step when they de-platform you
and they take you off the mainstream
platforms to silence you you don't prove
the man wrong you just prove it prove
that he has something to say that people
now really want to hear right
um plus I think he got even more reach
after they de-platform them because the
strategy with the um the kids using the
clips was just phenomenal that was
brilliant that was just great man it
never went away you didn't look canceled
to me either that's it at the end of the
day all these people who are competing
for attention is you know the youth or
you know young men or anyone really does
their message improve your life you know
all these internet celebrities I didn't
know a lot of them existed uh but you
know for being in in Tate's all but I've
come across a lot of them there are a
lot of people who are famous just for
the sake of being famous yeah they're
dancing clowns yes they might be amusing
but how do they adverted to your life if
someone follows Tate and you know the
tenants of Tate as per you know
corporate.com talks about yeah
accountability discipline talks about
being the man who protects and provides
all these positive masculine traits
which no one else is really putting out
there except for yourself and some
others in in similar sort of speaker
demographics those who follow tape their
lives are improved and some of them
drastically I walk around and take all
the time we have people walking out hey
how does University changed my life I
bought a car for my mum you know your
message has really helped me get back in
the gym your message has made me want to
you know have better relationships with
my parents if your message improves the
lives of your followers you're only
going to get more and more famous so all
these people are surprised about the
fact that they got famous quick I don't
I'm not surprised at all his message is
transformationally positive for those
who follow it of course he's going to
get famous so of course he's going to
stay famous you can't cancel a voice
that significantly improves people's
lives because they're hungry for more
it's it's simple market demand I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full-length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out